Hi, I'm Rich Hyndman.
The L Developer Preview
is well underway.
And I'm here in the
first of this series
of Dev Bytes with a super quick
rundown of the top features.
The most important
thing for developers
is that there are system
images available for the Nexus
5 and Nexus 7.
So now you can test your apps
and provide feedback to us
in the bug tracker
and Google+ community.
Head here, and set your project
to API level L to get started.
And one thing you're
sure to notice
is the new Material
design language.
Material provides
updates to the visual
of the interaction and the
motion design guidelines.
It replaces Holo, and introduces
a new theme.material along
with APIs for activity
transitions, shadows, reveals,
and more.
Notifications have
received an update
and now appear on
the lock screen
letting you surface content,
updates, and actions
to users at a glance.
There's three
visibility levels that
lets you manage the information
shown on secure lock screens.
We have VISIBILITY_PUBLIC
where the entire notification
is shown, VISIBILITY_PRIVATE
where it's just the application
name and, "Unlock your device
to see this notification,"
and VISIBILITY_SECRET that
doesn't show on the lock screen
at all.
If you choose Private
you can additionally
specify a separate, custom,
redacted notification
which would show on secure
lock screens instead.
Lock screens in the
L Developer Preview
no longer show controls if
you're a remote control client.
So instead you should provide
media playback control
through a notification.
Also if you don't
want the notification
to be sent to the user's
Android Wear device
you can use new Notification
Compat method setLocalOnly.
There is a non-Compat
version of the method
as well in Notifications,
but it applies
to API level 20 and above.
Whilst mentioning
API level 20, this
introduces Android
4.4 W. It's 4.4
with the wearable extensions.
The L Developer Preview
doesn't have its own API level,
and apps built against it
cannot be uploaded to Play.
We'll be incrementing
the API level
later on in the year
for the L release.
So if you check your
SDK Manager you'll
see those two new SDK
versions available,
4.4 W and the L
Developer Preview.
If you're building production
apps, build them against 4.4 W.
WebView has been updated
to Chrome M36, which
included support for Web Audio,
Undulating Monkeys, and Web
RTC, making it our most
advanced WebView yet.
And another big behind the
scenes update is the runtime.
The Art runtime
replaces Dalvik in L.
So please make sure you've
tested your apps soon.
Along with ahead-of-time
compilation,
improved garbage collection,
and improved debugging support,
also comes 64-bit support.
The majority of titles in the
Play Store are 64-bit ready,
and benefit with Art as they're
running purely Dex Bytecode.
Art's not only beneficial
for the memory footprint,
but also for battery life, which
brings us onto Project Volta.
As J focused on
[? junk?] removal,
and K made Android more svelte,
there's a big effort in L aimed
towards improving power tracking
and doing something about power
use.
So there's new
tools and APIs you
can use to help save
your user's battery.
For example, APIs so that you
can specify that a task should
be done if the phone
is charging whilst
on an unmetered
network like Wi-Fi,
and you want to guarantee that
it would start within an hour.
This is all done through
the Job Scheduler APIs.
There are also a couple of
new UI widgets in the support
library.
We have RecyclerView, an
advanced version of ListView
allowing you to
display and animate
rich, dynamic
collections, and CardView
that lets you display important
information inside a card which
uses the new elevation API in L.
Next we have the new
camera API, Camera2.
It provides access to full
resolution frames at full frame
rate with per frame
control of capture settings
and calibration metadata.
Staying with
multimedia, we've open
sourced the new video
player called ExoPlayer.
Built on top of Android's
low level media APIs,
it includes support for DASH
and smooth streaming adaptive
playback, providing
a new, flexible way
to enable video in
your applications.
Continuing in the same vein
we have audio updates as well.
With low latency audio,
multichannel high dynamic
range floating point mixing,
and USB audio support.
We've updated to Connectivity
with dynamic network selection
with seamless handoff,
and Bluetooth LE
gets an update including
peripheral mode.
And then we have, in order of
size, Android Wear, Android TV,
and Android Auto.
Don't forget to also
look out for all the I/O
material on these topics.
You can dive into
Wear and TV right now
as there are emulators
available for both.
Phew.
That is one hell of a preview.
We'll be going into more
details on the topics
in this video over the
next couple of months.
So stay tuned and happy coding.